MANO MARKS: I'm Mano Marks.
I'm Google Maps API developer
advocate, and I'm here with
Paul Rademacher, and Paul's
going to be talking about his
latest project which
is Stratocam.
But first, we're going to take
a couple minutes just to
introduce Paul because Paul is
fairly significant in the
history of Google Maps API.
He introduced the-- he actually
discovered the Google
Maps API and produced what is
widely regarded as the first
Google Maps Mashup, which
is a housingmaps.com.
So Paul, why don't you tell us
a little bit about that.
PAUL RADEMACHER: OK.
So a little bit extra about me,
so I actually used to work
at Google for several years.
I was here for five years on the
Earth team and Maps, and
left recently to go
to a new start up.
Before joining Google I was
working at DreamWorks
Animation and in 2005 Google
Maps had just come out.
There was no API.
It was awesome working
in graphics.
We dealt with large Hannibal
images all the time.
You know pan and zoom-able
images.
And so I literally remember the
day that Google Maps came
out, and we were all hunched
over the screen thinking, how
did nobody ever think of this?
At the time, though, Google
Maps was fairly static.
This is just in the first
couple of weeks.
And I started thinking about
what other kind of data might
make sense on a map.
And what if it were, you know,
what's the very fast moving
data type that might
be interesting.
I was looking for a place to
live, so I happened to be
spending a lot of time on
Craigslist. And I didn't
really know JavaScript.
I didn't really know what
Maps was doing.
But I knew enough.
I knew that the Maps code was
executing on the browser.
And so what I did was, I
grabbed the .js files.
I basically scraped the whole
Google Maps site images.
Not tiles.
Everything except for tiles.
Put them on my server, and then
started poking at the
files one by one to
see what it did.
And it was all obfuscated.
So there were no symbols.
Really couldn't figure out
what was going on.
But I started off by looking
at strings in JavaScript.
So I could see, right, that's
a really good place for
reverse engineering.
It's like, OK, I definitely
know this thing.
You know, this string
is not obfuscated.
There's a few function calls,
system calls are not
obfuscated.
So starting with that, little by
little, I poked at it until
I could set the position of
the map to what I wanted.
I poked at it until I could
get markers, and then info
windows to pop up.
And a few weeks later
I had a website.
Oh, I was also simultaneously
scraping housing listings from
Craigslist. And so about six
weeks of work later, I had
this demo put together, and
I posted on the Craigslist
housing forum, like on a
Thursday night and I said, hey
guys, I have this new thing
I'm working on, can
anybody test it?
And, in fact, I actually posted
on a Wednesday, first,
with that message, and then
people cussed me out.
Called me a spammer.
Because I didn't put the URL.
So they thought I was
selling something.
So I re-posted it the next
day with the URL.
That was Thursday night.
I wake up Friday and somebody,
some blogger noticed it.
So basically I roll into work
on Friday and somebody asked
me, they said, hey Paul, do you
know that there's a guy
with your name that just did
a cool map thing online?
And it was immediate insanity.
I had a, Gmail had just, I guess
Gmail had been out for
about a year, but my Gmail
account had, like, 100
messages in it.
Up to that day.
And then by the end
of the day it was,
like, a couple thousand.
And, it was just crazy.
That was, so this wound up being
the very first Google
Maps Mashup.
The very first third-party
website.
There was no API.
API was released a couple months
later, but I mean,
people immediately started
hacking on it,
even before an API.
And now, hundreds of thousands
of API sites later.
Here we are.
MANO MARKS: And we hadn't
actually intended, at Google
we hadn't intended to
release an API.
It wasn't even really just
something we thought about.
We're thinking, hey this
is a cool thing.
People can come to our site,
they can get driving
directions, whatever.
And then, that, Paul and then
later a few other people, just
showed us the tremendous, the
tremendous good that we could
do for the web by providing this
really easy way to put
maps on the site.
I was actually at a conference,
WhereCamp SoCal, a
couple years ago, and
I said, we were
presented with an option.
We could either hire
Paul or sue him.
And somebody from another large
geographic information
companies said, or you could
have killed him.
So we didn't, we chose--
PAUL RADEMACHER: Really?
MANO MARKS: Yeah.
PAUL RADEMACHER: Oh,
I didn't know that.
I didn't realize that
was an option.
MANO MARKS: Well, that, if you
worked at this other large
graphic information company,
which shall remain nameless,
apparently that's an option.
PAUL RADEMACHER: Wow.
MANO MARKS: But yeah, so we
chose, instead, to hire Paul
and set out to build
a Google Maps API.
We're really excited.
We're, I think, 700,000
websites now.
Pretty amazing for such a
short period of time.
PAUL RADEMACHER: It's
a nice number.
MANO MARKS: Yeah.
It is the most to used
API on the web.
So we're really happy and lucky
to have Paul with us.
Paul was the lead for the Google
Earth API as well.
He built that, and led the team
that's, that ultimately
published that.
So if you're interested in
putting Google Earth on your
website, you have a
way to do that.
But now I think you probably
want to talk about what you're
doing right now.
PAUL RADEMACHER: Sure.
So as a maps geek so I spend a
lot of time, obviously, as
part of my work, especially when
I was on the Earth team,
spent a lot of time looking
at satellite imagery.
Google Earth has a full-screen
mode which you guys are
probably all familiar with.
The word we use for, in talking
about full-screen
mode, is immersive.
So that's one of the things
when you, one of the great
things about Earth is, it takes
away every, you know,
the entire UI of the operating
system of, there's no browser
window decorations.
It's just the satellite view.
I think really few people
experience satellite imagery
with that level of immersion.
The majority of people who run
into, and do Google Map on a
day-to-day basis.
It's because they're trying to
get something else done.
Right?
So searching for a location,
getting driving directions,
right, between two points.
And map view suffices for
most of those use cases.
Satellite view is still great
for the average person when
they want to look up
their own house.
That's always, that's
always neat.
Or maybe just to see pictures
of some other country,
something on the news,
or whatever.
But still in the context of
maps.google.com, satellite
imagery is part of the show,
but it's not, it's
not 100% the star.
You're there to get work done.
So one of things that I enjoy
doing is discovering, usually
just randomly, just finding
places on the
map that look amazing.
Either because it's a man-made
structure looks really cool or
it's just a neat pattern
on the ground or
some colors or whatever.
And what I've done a few times
is, I'll find something on
maps, maps.google, grab the link
and then share it on my
preferred social network.
Right?
Just send it to people.
Like, here's a cool mansion, in
the middle of the suburb,
that you had no idea existed.
And that's great.
But after a few of these I
realized there's actually,
there's a lot of stuff
on the planet to see.
And there's more than just
one person can collect.
MANO MARKS: Why don't
we, why don't we
take a look, at Stratocam.
PAUL RADEMACHER: OK, and
are we full-screen?
Command Shift I think.
OK, so, let's see.
Josh, actually, can we
see the people again?
I want to confirm that everybody
can see this.
So can you guys out
there see this?
Yeah?
OK, awesome.
OK.
So, as I said before, the
typical thing that people do
on Google Maps, and on Google
Earth, the first thing a lot
of people do is type in
their street address.
Their home address.
They want to see what their
house looks like.
Right?
So this is somebody
else's house.
These are houses in Dubai.
If you happen to live in Dubai,
and you happen to have
a little bit of cash, then when
you look up your house
you'll find this.
And you might be impressed,
but this is
probably old news to you.
Right?
For most of the world
this is amazing.
MANO MARKS: I think this is
more than the top 1%.
PAUL RADEMACHER: Yes
MANO MARKS: This is
the top 0.1%.
PAUL RADEMACHER: Yes.
They should pay their
fair share.
So, so this is somebody's house
and this is somebody
else's version of a house.
Josh can we go to
the next one?
OK, so this is an airport.
This is Laguardia or JFK, one
of the two, I forget.
So we have all seen airports on
Google Maps because we're
trying to get there.
So you type in the airport as
your destination, but how
often do you switch to satellite
view and pull back a
little bit and just take
a look at what the
airport looks like?
So this is actually
one of my favorite
pictures that I've found.
MANO MARKS: That's really
nice, yeah.
And so, so it looks like you've
got a voting mechanism
on Stratocam to.
PAUL RADEMACHER: Right.
So, and before I talk about
the voting, so a couple of
these images on Stratocam, more
than a couple, as I was
working on it I collected, I try
to collect a lot of good
stuff for people see on
day one of lunch.
And I had collected about 200
images, which I thought were
pretty good.
And I had some of the greatest
hits, right.
Yeah, Josh, you can just feel
free to fast-forward.
So I had a lot of the greatest
hits, right?
Like Eiffel Tower, the Pentagon,
places like that.
I'd grabbed about 200 at lunch
and I worried, what if I
already found all
the best stuff?
Right?
So one of the things you can do
on Stratocam is anybody can
move the map around.
And, in fact, right now,
Josh, you could grab it
and just pan right.
So this is a Google
Maps API site.
It's built entirely on
tops of Maps API.
So at any point while you're
viewing the slide show of
images, you can move the map
around and eventually you'll
see a little camera icon
at the bottom.
That will let you take
a snapshot and
show it to other people.
When it launched I
had 200 images.
And then, right now the
total is around,
it's close to 30,000.
So 30,000 images submitted
by users.
And at the bottom there's a
thumbs up and thumbs down
buttons so people can also vote
for the best. And what
we're seeing here is a selection
of some of the best
images that people selected.
MANO MARKS: I told Paul he
should call it the Hot or Not
for satellite imagery.
I'm not sure if, if he's
allowed to do that.
PAUL RADEMACHER: I like it.
I think I'm allowed.
MANO MARKS: Yeah?
OK.
PAUL RADEMACHER: Let's
call it that.
MANO MARKS: That's your
elevator bit.
PAUL RADEMACHER: It is done.
MANO MARKS: This is amazing.
Do you--
PAUL RADEMACHER: This is--
MANO MARKS: --happen to
know what this is?
PAUL RADEMACHER: OK.
So I haven't been able to find
out exactly what this is.
This is right northeast
of London.
Some sort of island.
Yeah, one of the interesting
things that happens here is
people choose to discover things
on the ground that just
look interesting.
Asthetically pleasing.
But then, this is a great entry
point to learning about
geography, or what's
on the ground.
How far back are we?
Where is this?
This is San Diego.
This is actually not
a satellite image.
This is from the, this
is 45 degree imagery.
MANO MARKS: Yes.
PAUL RADEMACHER: Right?
MANO MARKS: Right.
This is aerial imagery,
or 45 degree imagery.
What we used to call obliques.
PAUL RADEMACHER: That's right.
And Maps API is really great in
that I can set, in fact I
set the map to 45 degrees
always, and then it
automatically toggles to 45
degrees if it's available.
And it's usually, usually
when it's
available, it's higher quality.
Sharper.
And lower to the ground.
And go ahead Josh.
In fact, hit p and we'll
just go automatically.
MANO MARKS: Josh, I think
somebody's not muted.
PAUL RADEMACHER: So this image
here, it says it's in the Baja
California region of Mexico.
This is clearly a
natural feature.
What you can't see
is that this is
it's over a mile across.
This is actually huge.
And it's, you know, you find all
around the planet, these
fractal shapes.
Right?
And, you know, what
more can we say?
It's beautiful.
MANO MARKS: Yeah.
PAUL RADEMACHER: This
is a great one.
This is the now non functioning
airport in Berlin.
Check out the tarmac.
It's enormous.
And Josh, hit minus to back
out a little bit.
You can see a little
more of it.
Again, as an entry point to
learning about geography or
history, in this case, if you
look up this airport on
Wikipedia you will learn
that this was the--
essentially command center
for the Berlin airlift.
Riyadh, Saudi Arabia.
There are a lot of circles
on the ground.
So people submitted--
MANO MARKS: These are, if I
recognize them from, if this
were in a US context, I would
definitely recognize this as
agricultural circles.
PAUL RADEMACHER: Right.
Yeah, that's what this is.
MANO MARKS: The irrigation
devices that go in a circular
pattern around a central pump.
PAUL RADEMACHER: Yeah.
MANO MARKS: Just pulling on my
vast agricultural knowledge.
PAUL RADEMACHER: Excellent.
Excellent.
What is this?
This is a picture of what?
Actually let's fast-forward
to the next one.
MANO MARKS: That's amazing.
I think, you know, as commuters
we don't think about
the beauty of highways.
But if you, I think designers of
the highways really thought
about this since they--
PAUL RADEMACHER: They definitely
thought about it.
Yeah.
Right, exactly.
Exactly.
The design, for all these
man-made structures, there's
some architect, who saw that
and marveled at it and said
I've created something
beautiful.
Right?
But you can only enjoy
it from high up.
Josh, let's go on.
OK, I think these
are different.
Crop circles.
But still in Saudi Arabia.
And I love the fact that that's
all desert except for
these green fields.
Circles.
More circles.
This is Sweden.
And go to the next one.
I think the next one is, in
fact, here we are in Rome.
MANO MARKS: Now you used the
Maps API to do this obviously.
I noticed, as we were zooming
out, but I didn't see any, are
you just using satellite mode?
Or, yeah.
Just satellite mode.
PAUL RADEMACHER: That was--
MANO MARKS: No roads or--
PAUL RADEMACHER: Back up one.
This is, this is the parking
lot outside Epcot Center.
So there you go.
Disney.
Disney World.
A curvy--
This is outside an Air Force
base in Southern California.
I don't know why the roads
are curved like that.
MANO MARKS: It almost looks
like a racetrack.
PAUL RADEMACHER: It looks
I don't think it is.
MANO MARKS: Ice flows?
That's what I would guess.
PAUL RADEMACHER: It is.
Yeah, this is Antarctica.
MANO MARKS: Antarctica.
PAUL RADEMACHER: Serbia.
One of the interesting things,
you can keep going Josh.
Thanks.
So one of the great things
about this site, lesson
learned for Maps
API developers.
When possible--
this, oh, this is a great one.
I'll make my point after
we look at this one.
So this is in, this is Canada.
This one is a fan favorite.
This is one of the most
up voted pictures.
MANO MARKS: 25 81, up votes.
Sensory
PAUL RADEMACHER: Yeah.
MANO MARKS: Yeah.
PAUL RADEMACHER:
2,500 up votes.
And you see the face?
MANO MARKS: Of course.
Yeah.
PAUL RADEMACHER: Right.
MANO MARKS: It's amazing.
PAUL RADEMACHER: And so
basically what this is, if you
look at the, if you could scan
the millions and millions of
hillsides and just
random geological
erosion patterns, right?
And uplift, and everything
else.
Eventually one of them
will resemble a face.
MANO MARKS: Right.
PAUL RADEMACHER: Right?
And that's what this is.
Now that the weird thing is
that he's wearing iPod
headphones.
I don't know what's
going on there.
MANO MARKS: I think Apple
paid for something.
PAUL RADEMACHER: That's right.
That's right.
It's an ad.
Steve Jobs.
Berlin.
It's a beautiful building.
What I was going to say before,
is this site doesn't
have really any text,
except for the
location of the bottom.
So it winds up being very,
very internationalized.
So this one is taken, by the
way, by our own Michael Jones.
MANO MARKS: Oh.
Nice.
PAUL RADEMACHER: Of the original
Google Earth team.
So this is a very
internationalized site.
So one of the neat things that I
get to witness here, is if a
link to Stratocam appears in,
say a Russian newspaper, which
has happened several times,
because the site is all
user-contributed content, then
for that time period, while
it's hot in Russia, all the
images on the front page will
start becoming images
of Russia.
MANO MARKS: Oh, right.
PAUL RADEMACHER: And
people will vote
for their own, right?
So I can actually see this app
changes constantly on the
24-hour cycle as
it goes, right.
MANO MARKS: That's right.
PAUL RADEMACHER: As
it goes around.
And it also assures, it also
makes it an interesting side
effect is then, the other
viewers from Russia are seeing
things that hit home.
MANO MARKS: Right.
PAUL RADEMACHER: Right?
This is the Forbidden
City in Beijing.
These are bats.
MANO MARKS: So we saw that
little shift there.
It actually shifts from the
satellite imagery right into
the aerial imagery, 45 degree.
PAUL RADEMACHER: That's,
that's right.
Yeah.
Maps transitioning.
This is Algeria.
Nothing but great colors.
More circles.
I think this is--
there's a few of these that
are really interesting.
This is a man-made circle.
Again, this is actually,
is that a spiral?
I think that's a spiral.
Oh, yeah.
There's a spiral pattern.
Not exactly sure what's
going on there.
MANO MARKS: That's amazing.
Suez Canal.
PAUL RADEMACHER: Suez Canal.
Yeah.
Vote captured.
The land mass of the earth is
150 kilometers squared.
So gives you a sense of how much
ground there is to cover.
Oh, this is actually one
of my favorites.
Favorites because it's so
beautiful and also bizarre.
So this is in the Congo.
This is vegetation on the
outskirts, on the edges of a
lake, of a large lake
in the Congo.
And you'll see those little
squiggly, little tiny spirals,
they're actually huge.
Each one of those is about
200 to 300 feet across.
MANO MARKS: Wow.
PAUL RADEMACHER: Right?
And the spirals just end
abruptly, so I spent half an
hour on Wikipedia and online in
trying, in looking up the
name of the lake, and we
couldn't figure out what's
going on here.
So this was a total mystery.
I kind of think it's man-made
channels by which to, you
know, maneuver boats.
MANO MARKS: Right.
PAUL RADEMACHER: But why
spirals, and why do they end
abruptly, I don't know.
This is, I think this is an
island outs, between Alaska
and Russia.
This is the Bahamas.
This beautiful blue.
Pirate ship.
Hannover Gardens in Germany.
This ones another
fan favorite.
People love this image.
2,300 up votes.
MANO MARKS: So I'm thinking that
it might be good to start
taking some questions
from the hangout.
So let's see.
If you've got a question for
Paul, why don't you raise your
hand and we will unmute you
and bring you back in.
Yes.
Eric
ERIC: Am I unmuted?
MANO MARKS: Yeah, you're fine.
Yeah.
ERIC: Oh.
Cool.
One of the things that I love
about Google Maps and Google
Earth is just kind of playing
with them like a video game
you can assimilate so much
information and understanding
about what's going on
with the geography.
And I do that was Stratocam
as well, so I like to flip
through really quick and
understand different
places in the world.
And I'd love it if I could
filter out the points that
don't have the place labeled.
So what I end up doing a lot of
times is, I will zoom out
and try to figure out where that
place is, and then try to
pull it up in Google Maps and
then find it in Google Earth
and then explore around that
place if it's interesting.
And further to that point, as
this gains popularity, it
seems like it would be wonderful
to be able to
categorize different places
like, you could cruise through
all the agriculture, interesting
agriculture spots,
or the cities or villages.
And you could really quickly
start to educate yourself
about structures of culture and
agriculture and everything
else like that.
So I was curious about your
future development plans along
those lines.
PAUL RADEMACHER: Yeah,
so that's a, those
are two great points.
Categories, some form of
categorization, is actually
right at the top of
my to-do list.
ERIC: Mmmhmm.
PAUL RADEMACHER: Categorization,
both
thematically, as you said.
Interesting agricultural items.
As I mentioned before,
there's tons of circles on the
ground, and I want to circles
collection.
I actually want to just go
through and look at all the
circles that people discover.
ERIC: Right.
Yeah, yeah.
PAUL RADEMACHER: Also, also in
geography, the two, I would
say, I would say the three most
interesting places, or
sources of snapshots, are
Russia, Northeast Russia,
Saudi Arabia--
ERIC: Yeah.
PAUL RADEMACHER: --and
the Netherlands.
Surprisingly the Netherlands has
just beautiful castles and
forts and water channels, you
know, plowing through fields.
ERIC: Yeah.
PAUL RADEMACHER: So I would
like to see those as
collections, right.
Just show me stuff in
the Netherlands.
So that's at the top
of the list and I
think it'll be great.
ERIC: Awesome.
PAUL RADEMACHER: The other, the
other point, some items,
some snapshots surprisingly
don't have location.
What I do is, the user submits
a snapshot, and that winds up
just being latitude
and longitude,
and the view extense.
And then, on the back end,
I send it to the Google
geocoder, and I try to parse,
you get a big--
ERIC: Oh, OK.
PAUL RADEMACHER: --dump of data
and then try to parse the
interesting stuff.
I do need to run a second
geoencoding pass to pick up
some stuff that they didn't
geocode the first time that I
think I could do better
at on a second run.
There is a secret feature.
If you hit A, the letter
A, it will actually pop
up labels in Stratocam.
ERIC: Oh, cool.
MANO MARKS: So is that
switching to
the hybrid map type?
PAUL RADEMACHER: It switches
to hybrid map.
Right.
ERIC: Awesome.
Oh, that's awesome.
PAUL RADEMACHER: So that's
useful, it's useful for that.
The concept thing I ran into in
the app, is I try to keep
it the UI super,
super minimal.
ERIC: Yeah.
PAUL RADEMACHER: Because, you
know, most, 99% of people
don't need two labels.
But for that 1% that they really
do want to see them, I
want to support that.
So I'm going to make the labels
feature more prominent.
ERIC: Cool.
And then, and then, one other
quick question and I can give
someone else a chance.
As I cruise through all of
these spots what I end up
doing when I thumb-up something,
or a place is
compelling to me, and going into
Google Earth and looking
up that location, finding
the lat/long,and
then plugging it in--
[RECORDED VOICES]
ERIC: --I end up going
into Google Maps--
[RECORDED VOICE]
MALE VOICE (OFFSCREEN):
OK, you're back.
PAUL RADEMACHER: Time
warp going on here.
OK, go, go ahead.
I think we'll be OK.
ERIC: OK, cool.
Anyway,
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ERIC: I would love to be able
to download a KML of all of
the points that I've found up
and be able to plug that into
Google Earth, and explore
those places--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PAUL RADEMACHER: I heard
your question.
We're fixing the echo.
It was a good question.
I think we got the echo
under control here.
I did see recently a guy, Daniel
Dye, d-y-e, took the
Stratocam feed and built
a KML file out of it.
And we chatted a little
bit about that.
Yeah, having maybe, like,
Stratocam, you know, question
mark, output equals KML,
or something like that.
And like right now, you can go
to, go to Stratocam slash API,
and you'll see the JSON dump,
of the snapshots.
That's our, you know, the
JavaScript [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So API question mark, output
equals KML, to
give the same data.
Format is KML would be super
easy, and then I believe you
would be able to just go to
Google Earth and just pop in
Stratocam da-da-da, and ingest
directly in Earth.
And I could even I
put it as a tour.
That's what Dan Dye was doing.
Yeah, that'd be great.
MANO MARKS: Yeah.
PAUL RADEMACHER:
That'd be fun.
ERIC: Sweet.
You know, again, I just love
to use it as a tool for
exploring and just
let, putting the
world into my brain.
PAUL RADEMACHER: Cool, thanks.
ERIC: Yep.
MANO MARKS: Cool.
Thanks, Eric.
Is there somebody else that
has a question for Paul?
Wave your hand if you do.
Pierre.
PIERRE: Hi Paul.
MANO MARKS: It's un-muted.
PIERRE: Kind of on
a similar theme.
I'd really like to, sort of,
be able to browse the
Stratocam by the
highest rated.
So is there a way to browse, you
know, to see whose got the
most vote with two images,
who got the most votes?
PAUL RADEMACHER: There is.
Another secret feature.
I need a user guide for this.
I've got a few things.
If you go to Stratocam/top,
you can do that today.
Yeah.
I'll do a better job of putting
links up and say
here's all the different
use of it.
But, yeah, slash top right now
works, and it'll show you the
most, the most uploaded.
Oh, something we're hoping to
release, myself and my friend,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], is a
screen-saver, a Mac
screen-saver, which
actually goes to,
pulls from, slash top.
And it's a great, you know, I
show this to people and I say
this would make an awesome
screen-saver.
It feels like a screen-saver.
Just a couple of technical
issues to work out.
MANO MARKS: Right.
PAUL RADEMACHER: Like making
sure that when you run the
screen-saver you don't rate
limit yourself on Google Maps.
MANO MARKS: Yeah.
Right.
Cool.
Anyone else have a question
for Paul?
Cool.
So how are we doing
on time Josh?
OK, so I think what we'll do
now is we'll shift over to
general Maps API questions.
So if anybody has any you
can ask that, or we
can go to the moderator.
So if you have any, have a
question, or you want to say
something, raise your hand.
I can't see if anybody's
raising their hand.
Sorry.
Raise your hand if you
have a question.
No?
OK.
I do want to pull
open the chat.
So I see if anybody has written
anything in chat.
OK.
No.
OK, good.
So we're going to, go to,
the moderator and
see what we've got.
OK, so the first question is,
are you still developing
fusion tables, and will we be
able to use this to port to
the pop-up info windows?
So, yeah, fusion table's
still a going
concern here at Google.
It's a beta project.
We're still working on it.
It comes out of our Google
Research arm.
We have an experimental feature
that allows you to put
that on top of a Google,
Google Maps API.
I'm not sure what this means.
Is that, is Jeremy part of the,
I don't know if Jeremy's
part of the hangout, but
I don't see him there.
But currently, what you can
do, is you can actually
capture the click event that
happens on a fusion table
layer, and that allows you to,
to get the information that
would otherwise be into the info
window, and then you can
customize the info
window yourself.
So I hope that answers
your question Jeremy.
OK, so the next one is KML.
What is the best way to keep
performance with no clustering
and almost 100,000 points?
Try to keep the visual
distribution points while
keeping the ability to click
to get more info?
So, 100,000 points is, is a lot
of points for a KML file.
KML, if you're talking about
on top of Google Maps, I'm
really actually not
sure if this is a
Maps or Earth question.
If you're talking about on top
of Google Maps, what you
probably want to do is actually
shift over to using
fusion tables and the fusion
table layer for the moment.
Another thing that you can do
is you can do a network link
which will only open up certain,
will only load in
points, when you are to certain
zoom level or you're
close to it.
So you can do what's
called a originated
network link hierarchy.
This works really well
in Google Earth.
So as you zoom in, it loads in
more points [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
the relevant areas.
This would be a good question
for [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
figure out what we're doing
all of our tech
support for KML now.
Let's go on to the next.
Will this app appear
on Google TV?
So I think this is probably
a question for Paul.
PAUL RADEMACHER: It's
a great idea.
Just like the screen-savers.
MANO MARKS: And it is HTML, so
it's just a web-page so you
can load onto Google TV. It'd be
great to have some sort of
app that did that, like
a screen-saver.
PAUL RADEMACHER: Yeah.
Super fun.
MANO MARKS: Can you share any
points where balloon mapping
imagery has been integrated?
What is the submission
process?
So we have integrated
some elements.
We recently got imagery from
a group called Public
Laboratory, and we have a lot
of the public domain imagery
from Public Laboratory
is in Google Earth.
At this point I believe what
we do is we put it into our
historical imagery, rather
than have it integrated
directly with the top-level
imagery.
So, I don't know if, I think we
have some in New York City.
Is that, I, I'm not sure
where that is.
We actually have some in New
Orleans, and I believe we
actually did a blog post on this
recently that had a KML
file you could download.
So if you go to the Google long
blog you can check out
that, that site, and see, I
think there's also a KML file
that can be uploaded
from there.
PAUL RADEMACHER: And Google
Earth also has kite imagery.
MANO MARKS: Yes.
Yeah.
We also have, we also have
kite imagery in a
few places as well.
So, yeah, this, this really
interesting thing, just for
those who are wondering, Public
Laboratory and many
others, are experimenting with
basically point and click
cameras that you just
[INAUDIBLE]
the button and send it up in the
air and it takes a bunch
of imagery.
[INAUDIBLE]
for an hour, and it takes
a whole bunch.
And you get some, you get some
really interesting, beautiful
and very close up imagery.
So you can get, you can get
something that is pretty high
resolution compared to what you
can get from satellite.
ERIC: Am I still muted?
Or am I connected
with you guys?
MANO MARKS: You're, Eric
is, you're still in.
ERIC: Oh, OK, cool.
A little further to that
question, can I cut in there?
MANO MARKS: Yeah.
ERIC: Kind of the reason I was
interested in the balloon
mapping was--
MANO MARKS: Oh, that was you.
ERIC: Yeah.
Yeah.
I'm Eric.
Was on the University of Montana
campus we have old
imagery, or old satellite
images, which don't include
some of the current
built buildings.
And one of the criticisms that
I was getting from my
supervisor was that the Google
Maps API and approach wasn't
good enough because it didn't
keep pace with the development
of the campus.
So that was kind of a little bit
of my, I participated in
that Public Laboratory
kick-starter, and bought a
balloon thing with my own;
money, and I was going to try
to make my own updated satellite
images and submit
them, and then be able, once
those were, and the problem
with the old satellite images
is that I couldn't put the
footprints in the mapmaker and
update the sidewalk lines
because it was still
the old images.
So I ran up against this
continued criticism that
Google Maps couldn't
keep pace.
And the Achilles heel was the
old satellite images.
MANO MARKS: So that's really
good feedback for us and we do
have an imagery submission
process.
You can actually, if you search
it, you can find--
or is that donating imagery?
Giving imagery to Google for,
for Maps you can get that and
then we can make it as
part of our regular.
ERIC: OK.
And then, and then with that
note, with that note then it
would be hopefully be pushed
into the Google Maps instead
of just a historic layer
in the earth.
MANO MARKS: Yeah, I mean, it
would depend on the imagery
and the quality of imagery.
I'm not on imagery
team myself.
ERIC: OK.
MANO MARKS: Yeah, so
search for that.
Or you can ping me on Google+
and we'll figure out how to
how to get you're imagery.
ERIC: OK.
Great.
MANO MARKS: All right.
So I think those are all the
questions from the moderator.
Are there any more
from the hangout?
No?
OK.
Any last words Paul?
PAUL RADEMACHER: None from me.
MANO MARKS: OK.
PAUL RADEMACHER: Just
thanks everybody.
MANO MARKS: Yeah.
Thanks everybody.
Thanks for coming.